الينا من عمان الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه اللواء فايز الدويري سيد
لواء ما هو تفسيرك لعوده كيف لخط المواجهه
والقصف الروسي
يعني منذ استهداف جسر كرش من قبل اوكرانيا
قبل عده اشهر بدات روسيا تستخدم الصواريخ
لمهاجمه الاهداف الحيويه وذات التاثير
والارتدادات على البيئه الاجتماعيه
الحاضنه وبالتالي استهدفت طيب واسع لكنها
ركزت بصوره مطلقه على مهاجمه محطات الطاقه
والمياه قبل فصل الشتاء ومع بدايه فصل
الشتاء لماذا لان هناك دراسات همم
لمركز جلوبال وغيره
اظهرت ان منطقه كيف وليفيف لا تزال البيئه
الاجتماعيه الداعمه لاستمرار الحرب
بنسبه 82% في كياف وتقريبا 84% فيليف
بينما في شرق وجنوب نهر الدينابر كانت 52
و54 ولكن الاستهداف كانت تقريبا يغطي
الجغرافيا الاوكراني الجغرافيا الاوكرانيه
لماذا لان استحقاقات الميدان لم تكن
بالمستوى المطلوب ثلاثه انتكاسات عسكريه
رئيسيه في كيف في خير كيف في غرسون وعجز
تام عن تحقيق اي انتصار يرد الاعتبار
فبالتالي كان لابد من مهاجمه الاهداف
الرخوه لكن انعكاسات كبيره جدا على البيئه
الاجتماعيه الحاضر الداعمه فت تركيز على
منطقه كيف وغير كيف لانه معظم المناطق
تتعرف لكن كيف هي العاصمه والاكبر مركز
الثقل السياسي فبالتالي ستعاقب اكثر من
غيرها ولكن استهداف مناطق حيويه
وتستخدم المجتمع الاوكراني او مناطق مدنيه
هل هي في مفهوم الحرب تعتبر جرائم حرب ام
ان في الحرب كل شيء مشروع
لا ليس كل شيء مشروع هناك القوانين
الناظمه للحرب هناك مواثيق جنيف تحدد تحدد
همم قطر المسموح بها ولكن للاسف منذ الحرب
العالميه الاولى والحرب العالميه الثانيه
والحرب الكوريه والحرب الفيتناميه الاولى
والثانيه مرورا بحروب الشرق الاوسط
العراقيه الايرانيه وعاصفه الصحراء وال
2003 ظهور داعش لا يوجد اي احترام او
تطبيق لقوانين الحرب الناظمه ولا
الاتفاقيات جنيف انما يتم انتقاء الاهداف
التي تحقق
الغير السياسيه الان الغايه السياسيه
الوصول الى مخرج روسيا تتحدث عن الوصول
الى اتفاق تحت شروط يجب الاعتراف والاقرار
بها وهي الواقع الميداني هذا مرفوض
بالمطلق من قبل من قبل اوكرانيا وبالت
مركز جلوبال كما اشرت لك اعطى ان 84% من
الشعب لسه مع استمرار القتال اذا يجب
معاقبه هذا الشعب للضغط على القياده
السياسيه من اجل الانصياع والذهاب الى همم
المفاوضات خاصه مع التوجه الغربي الذي
يشجع اوكرانيا على الانفتاح على المفاوضات
العسكريه والاستراتيجيه متحدثا من عمان
شكرا جزيلا لك